The Man From UNCLE is directed by Guy
Ritchie and stars Henry Cavill and Armie
Hammer and is the adaptation of the
classic 60s television show of the same
name
henry cavill plays a CIA agent who has
different ideals with a KGB agent played
by army hammer and they have to work
together to stop this nuclear
something-or-other from happening
because the end of the world and it's
terrible and you know big stuff could
happen and it's bad and they have to
stop it like every movie ever I was
looking forward to seeing this movie
though because I think when Guy Ritchie
really nails it he has a very unique
style and one that can make a movie that
you would think normally very
conventional unconventional and I was
hoping that the Man From UNCLE would be
like that and well I don't think this is
necessarily a bad movie I didn't really
find it very interesting I found it very
uneven intone it shifts quite often from
very silly fun spy movie with henry
cavill sleeping with tons of women and
making jokes about army hammers Russian
accent with a terrific opening action
sequence that really set henry cavill
and army hammers characters at odds with
one another that was a great throwback
to 1960 spy movies when they didn't take
themselves too seriously in the two
leads had excellent chemistry with one
another they worked really well together
they were funny together they played off
each other extremely well unfortunately
it becomes very uneven when the movie
tries to get a lot more serious as well
as some of the directing style of the
action that completely takes on this
modern-day more shaky-cam effect which
you know I hate but I understand when it
can be used effectively the issue is
that the movie is trying to be also a
60s throwback and it does a lot of that
very well but there's a lot of
modern-day attempts at making it very
okay for today's audiences as well in
some of the way the action is directed
and I think those two elements really
clashed and didn't work well with one
another the major issue I had with this
movie though is the story I found it
really uninteresting it's your basic
spies have to stop somebody who's an
evil guy and he's got bombs and there's
nothing inventive really about it and
the characters were kind of bland
despite the fact that they were
portrayed in an entertaining way
sometimes it would be kind of like
Ocean's eleven were you shown something
happens and you think that's how it
played out then some guy comes and goes
actually that's not how it happened let
me revert back a few
and then you go in flashback form and
you see what actually took place you're
like oh it's clever and it was okay that
first time but in the film did it like
four more times and I was like at what
point is this story just gonna play out
or are we going to keep reverting to
various flashbacks to tell us what
actually happened in regards to Henry
Cavill I think he was very energetic in
this movie he was very suave I can see
why some people were considering him for
bond for a while it's probably the most
energy I've seen out of him since
as far as army hammer goes I really
don't understand what told him to take
on another character from an adaptation
of a classic TV show didn't really work
out last time all in all the Man From
UNCLE is not a bad movie I would say
it's just an incredibly uneven one it
goes from fun spy film to serious drama
where army hammers character has these
bouts of incredible anger and you're not
really sure if you're supposed to be
laughing because the tone is so
inconsistent and while they work well
with each other in the opening action
scene was a lot of fun every other
action scene after that disappointed me
and the story itself I found very bland
and I was honestly a bit bored for the
most of the runtime of this movie I'm
going to give the man From UNCLE a C+
guys will have my review for straight
out of Compton
tomorrow I'm looking forward to seeing
that movie thank you so much as always
for watching if you did see this movie
I'd like to know your thoughts on it
also check out my review for The Sixth
Sense it's starting my M night Shyamalan
series leading up to the visit as always
guys I appreciate your viewership thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck Benoist
you